SEAN HANNITY HAS THAT COVERED.
TAKES OVER.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
THE INSANITY, THE RAGE IN
AMERICA IS REACHING A FEVERED
PITCH.
THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND AS WE SPEAK,
DEMOCRATS ARE PLOTTING,
PLANNING, SCHEMING TO OVERTHROW
THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
REMOVE THIS DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE BASED ON
AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS IS NOT AN IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING IN ANY WAY, THIS IS A
FULL-FLEDGED POLITICAL COUP
ATTEMPT.
IT IS AN ILLEGITIMATE,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CLOWN SHOW.
TONIGHT, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS FIGHTING BACK
HARD AND LETTING DEMOCRATS DID
THEIR OWN THE HOLE.
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT TO
PALLONE HAS ISSUED WHAT IS A
DEVASTATING TAKEDOWN OF THE
DEMOCRATS' ATTEMPTED COUP AND A
LETTER TO NANCY PELOSI, THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF, MADE THING ONE
CLEAR, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WILL NOT PARTICIPATE OR
COOPERATE WITH THE DEMOCRATS'
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN VALID
BASELESS SO-CALLED INQUIRY.
YOU MUST NOT LEGITIMIZE THAT
WHICH IS ILLEGITIMATE.
EVERY REPUBLICAN NEEDS TO STAND
BY OUR CONSTITUTION, RULE OF
LAW, DUE PROCESS, PAST
PRESIDENTS, AND BY THE WAY, HOW
SPEAKER GINGRICH DID IT IN THE
1990s AGAINST THEN PRESIDENT
BILL CLINTON.
THEY ARE NOT OFFERING ANYTHING
NEAR THAT.
THE REPUBLICANS, WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS, AND OTHERS MUST NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS ILLEGITIMATE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MADNESS.
LET THE DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS,
THEY CAN OWN AT ALL.
THIS IS THEM.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE.
IN THE END, THEY'VE DONE NOTHING
BUT HATE TRUMP.
NOT ABOUT TRUTH, NOT ABOUT LAW,
NOT ABOUT A FACT-FINDING
MISSION.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH POLITICAL
WITCH HUNTS.
BYRON YORK QUOTING GOVERNMENT
REPORTING THAT PELOSI WON'T GO
TO COURT TO ENFORCE THE
SUBPOENAS.
THE HOUSE WILL KEEP TURNING OUT
SUBPOENAS BASED ON WHAT'S KNOWN
NOW, WHICH IS NOTHING, PLUS
OBSTRUCTION WHICH ANSWERS THE
UNCOVERED SUBPOENAS BIT LIKE
McDONALD'S, RUNNING OUT IN A
MINUTE.
RUNNING DEEP IN THE DEMOCRATS
'
HIS WORDS WERE DEVASTATING, I'LL
GET TO THAT.
WE TAKE A STEP BACK.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER HOW DID WE
GET HERE?
NOW THERE ARE THREE FUND MENTAL
THINGS AT PLAY.
ONE, THE LEFT IN AMERICA, THE
MEDIA MOB, THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO ACCEPT THE TRUTH AND THE
REALITY WHICH IS THE RESULTS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
TWO, WE HAD FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, BIPARTISAN SENATE
COMMITTEE, AND GUESS WHAT,
CULMINATING WITH MUELLER'S
REPORT.
NO COLLUSION.
IMPEACHMENT DREAMS SHATTERED.
THREE, THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T BEAT
TRUMP.
THEY'VE BEEN SAYING IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT
IMPEACHMENT TALK MAY HELP THE
PRESIDENT'S REELECTION?
>> I'M CONCERNED THAT IF WE
DON'T IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT, HE
WILL GET REELECTED.
IF WE DON'T IMPEACH HIM, HE WILL
STAY.
HE HAS BEEN VINDICATED.
SPEAKING
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY WE ARE
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
ALL STARTED IN THE DAY THAT WE
THE PEOPLE, YOU THE AMERICAN
VOTERS, SHOCK THE WORLD AND PICK
DONALD TRUMP TO BE THE
DISRUPTIVE, ICONOCLASTIC
PRESIDENT YOU ELECTED.
THE LEFT COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
THEY SNAPPED, QUITE FRANKLY.
EVERY DAY SINCE NOVEMBER 8TH,
2016, THEY HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITH US IN RAGE, BUT SMELLY
WALMART SHOPPER, I'M GUILTY,
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, THE
ONES WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP CLING
TO THEIR GOD GIVEN BIBLES AND
RELIGION.
HUNDREDS OF ANTI-TRUMP
PROTESTERS MARCH IN DALLAS TO
REBEL AGAINST THE ELECTION.
TWO DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION,
10TH OF NOVEMBER 2016, FIRE
ERUPTS, VANDALISM REPORTED,
ANTI-TRUMP PROTEST IN OAKLAND.
THOUSANDS PROTEST TRUMP ELECTION
IN L.A., BLOCK THE 101 FREEWAY
IN DOWNTOWN.
IN NEW YORK, PROTESTERS RETURNED
TO TRUMP TOWER FOR A SECOND
NIGHT AFTER TRUMP'S BIG ELECTION
WIN.
LOUISVILLE SAW A "NOT MY
PRESIDENT" PROTEST THE SAME
DEBRIS NOVEMBER 11TH, SAME STORY
IN PHILLY, ANOTHER PROTEST IN
MIAMI, INDIANAPOLIS, ON AND ON
AND ON.
DEMOCRATS CALL FOR THIS
PRESIDENT TO BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE BEFORE HE WAS EVER CLOSE
TO BE SWORN IN.
BY THE WAY, THEIR COMPLIANT
FRIENDS, THE DNC STENOGRAPHERS,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, LIARS KNOWN
AS THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ECHO THE
HYSTERIA ON TELEVISION.
FOLLOW THE TIMELINE HERE.
YOU MAY WANT TO RUN YOUR DVR.
STARTING TWO DAYS AFTER ELECTION
DAY, THIS IS WHAT BROUGHT US TO
THIS POINT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF HE TAKES THE RISK GOING TO
TRIAL AND IS CONVICTED, THAT
COULD BE SEEN AS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> IF TRUMP WERE CAUGHT ON A
VIDEO CAMERA SNORTING COCAINE ON
THE VIDEO CAMERA MAY BE WITH HIS
CHILDREN, THERE MAY BE A CHANCE
HE WOULD BE IMPEACHED.
>> IS HE NOT A LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT IN YOUR MIND, THERE
ARE TOOLS THAT CONGRESS HAVE.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW THAT WOULDN'T
BE AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> THAT TWEET FITS THE
REPUBLICAN DEFINITION OF AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> I WILL FIGHT EVERY DAY UNTIL
HE IS IMPEACHED!
IMPEACH 45!
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> FOR US, AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> IS IMPEACHMENT THE
APPROPRIATE REMEDY --
>> SOMETHING FOR CONGRESS LIKE
IMPEACHMENT?
>> ALL OF THAT MAY BE
IMPEACHABLE.
>> THAT'S AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> IS THAT AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE TO YOU?
>> HE'S MUCH MORE VULNERABLE TO
IMPEACHMENT.
>> A POTENTIAL INGREDIENT OF
>> WHERE DO YOU SEE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE?
>> IT IS GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
>> POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL OR EVEN
IMPEACHABLE --
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT OR
DOES THAT GO FAR ENOUGH IN YOUR
VIEW?
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> THIS TWEET ALONE MAY BE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT IS ON THE TABLE.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE --
>> MAYBE THEY DON'T BECAUSE
WE'LL GO IN THERE AND WILL
IMPEACH [BLEEP] --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> DO YOU SEE AN IMPEACHABLE SET
OF OFFENSES?
>> IT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> IF THAT'S NOT IMPEACHABLE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHALL BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE ON
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IS IT IMPEACHABLE?
100% IS IMPEACHABLE!
>> VERY SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THE
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> TIPPING POINT, THE TALK OF
IMPEACHMENT REACHES A FEVER
PITCH ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, THERE WAS
THE INSURANCE POLICY IN PLACE
AND IT WAS CALLED OPERATION
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE.
THAT WAS THE NINE-MONTH FBI
COUNTER INTEL INVESTIGATION THAT
ONLY A PRESIDENT COULD HAVE
THAT, THAT IT BE OBAMA, IN ALL
THINGS TRUMP AND RUSSIA,
PRUSSIA, RUSSIA, THAT CAME UP
EMPTY, MD, MD.
EVEN PETER STRZOK ADMITTED THERE
WAS NO THERE THERE.
IT WAS A 22 MONTH SPECIAL
COUNSEL WITCH HUNTS, RUSSIA
COLLUSION, THAT CAME UP EMPTY
TOO.
NO COLLUSION, NO CONSPIRACY,
NOTHING.
ROBERT MUELLER IS BIASED
TESTIMONY AND EMBARRASSMENT FOR
DEMOCRATS, FOUR INVESTIGATIONS
CLEAR THE PRESIDENT IN A
WRONGDOING BUT NO DUE PROCESS
FROM THAT CORRUPT MEDIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING
IMPEACHMENT FROM DAY ONE.
DEMOCRATS ECONOMICALLY
SECRETLY SEARCHING,
SEEKING, AND MEETING THE DEMANDS
FOR THEIR RADICAL BASE.
THEY WENT FROM THE STORMY CREW
TO A TAX RETURN TO AND NOW THEY
SET TO A MANUFACTURED SCANDAL
SURROUNDING UKRAINE AND DO THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO IGNORE THE
REAL SCANDAL OF JOE BIDEN AND
HIS SON.
POOR LUCY MADE LOUD AND CLEAR
THAT DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THERE ARE
MANY, MANY GOOD OPTIONS FOR
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT.
WE'VE JUST GOT TO PICK ONE OUT
OF A HAT.
BUT THIS TIME INSTEAD OF RELYING
ON A LENGTHY INVESTIGATION TO BE
THWARTED BY SPECIAL COUNSEL,
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE MATTERS
IN THEIR OWN HANDS.
NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN.
THEY WILL JUST USE AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
BLITZ AS WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT
CIPOLLONE, HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DESIGNED AN INQUIRY THAT
VIOLATES FUNDAMENT OF FAIRNESS
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED DUE
PROCESS.
THEY HAVE DENIED THE PRESIDENT
THE RIGHT TO CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES, TO CALL WITNESSES, TO
RECEIVE TRANSCRIPTS OF
TESTIMONY, TO HAVE ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE, TO HAVE COUNSELED THE
PRESIDENT, AND SO MANY OTHER
BASIC, SIMPLE POND MENTAL
GUARANTEED RIGHTS OF ALL
AMERICANS.
ALL THIS VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION, THE RULE OF LAW
AND EVERY PAST PRESIDENT.
NEWT GAVE THEM ALL OF THAT WHEN
THEY IMPEACH CLINTON.
SIMPLY, DEMOCRATS SEEK TO
OVERTURN THE RESULT OF THE 2016
ELECTION AND DEPRIVE YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OF THE
PRESIDENT THEY HAVE FREELY
CHOSEN.
MANY DEMOCRATS NOW VIEW
IMPEACHMENT NOT ONLY AS A MEANS
TO UNDO THE DEMOCRATIC RESULTS
OF THE LAST ELECTION BUT AS A
STRATEGY TO INFLUENCE THE NEXT
ELECTION WHICH IS BARELY A YEAR
AWAY.
AND CONCLUDED, "GIVEN THE
INQUIRY LACKS ANY LEGITIMATE
CONSTITUTIONAL FOUNDATION, ANY
PRETENSE OF FAIRNESS, OR EVEN
THE MOST ELEMENTARY DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS, THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS BECAUSE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS INQUIRY
UNDER THE CURRENT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL POSTURE WOULD
INFLICT LASTING INSTITUTIONAL
HARM ON THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH."
MEANING FUTURE PRESIDENTS.
THE PRESIDENT, CALLED IT RIGHTLY
SO AKON PERPETRATED AGAINST
AMERICANS LED BY SCHIFF, THE
COWARDLY, THE LYING SCHIFF
AND SPEAKER AND NAME PELOSI AND
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC CLOWN SHOW
THAT IS CAPITOL HILL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE DEFRAUDED THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CAN HAPPEN,
BUT THERE ARE THOSE WHO SAY HE
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED FOR WHAT HE
DID.
HE CERTAINLY SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
IT'S ALL A BIG CON, DON'T YOU
UNDERSTAND -- LOOK, THE PHONE
CALL, YOU HAVE IT!
IT'S THIS TRANSCRIPT.
THAT'S WHY THEY SAY THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER SAID THIS AND
THAT, WHAT HAPPEN IS THEY
WOULD'VE SEEN THE TRANSCRIPT
EARLY, THEY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD A
WHISTLE-BLOWER BECAUSE HE
WOULDN'T HAVE SAID -- THERE WAS
NOTHING HE COULD SAY.
THESE ARE CROOKED PEOPLE.
THESE ARE DEMOCRATS ADDED BY A
DEMOCRAT LAWYER, A BIG DEMOCRAT
LAWYER.
IT'S A BIG CON JOB BEING
PERPETRATED ON THE UNITED STATES
PUBLIC -- AND EVEN THE WORLD.
>> Sean: THE COWARDLY SHIFTY
SCHIFF.
HE HAS THE TRANSCRIPT BUT IT
EXONERATED THE PRESIDENT SO HE
MADE UP A NEW ONE FOR THAT'S HOW
PATHETIC AND DESPERATE THEY ARE
AT DENYING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA'S
ALL RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS, TRYING
TO RUSH IMPEACHMENT ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE WITHOUT ANY REAL
INVESTIGATION, ANY COUNTER
ARGUMENTS, WITHOUT ANY
INVESTIGATIONS, WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY WANT TO DO IT IN TOTAL
SECRECY AND MORE IMPORTANT THERE
ARE NO CRIMES, NO TREASON, AND
THE BRIBERY -- WAIT A MINUTE,
THERE IS BRIBERY.
BECAUSE BIDEN IS BRAGGING ON
TAPE ABOUT BRIBING UKRAINE WITH
A BILLION TAXPAYER DOLLARS
UNLESS THEY FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING HIS SON IN SIX
HOURS.
SON OF A B, THEY DID IT.
THERE IS NO CONSTITUTIONALITY,
NO VALID REASON FOR WHAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
ZERO.
AND SO FAR, THERE HASN'T BEEN A
ROLL CALL VOTE TO PROCEED.
NEVER MIND THE RULES, THE LAWS
THAT ARE GOING TO GOVERN THIS
CIRCUS, THIS THREE-RING CIRCUS
OF THE DEMOCRATS.
WHY?
PELOSI, YOU SEE THOSE NAMES, PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION TO AND SHE'S
TRYING TO PROTECT THOSE 40
PEOPLE IN DISTRICTS THAT DONALD
J. TRUMP WON IN 2016.
THOSE PEOPLE IN NORTHERN DAYS
ARE NUMBERED IF THEY GO OUT AND
VOTE.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, THOSE 40 OR
SO DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE
COMPLICIT.
THEY AREN'T SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
THIS WITCH HUNT.
TONIGHT IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
HOUSE REPUBLICANS FOLLOW THE
LEAD OF THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
LET THESE POST CONSTITUTIONAL
DEMOCRATS DID THEIR OWN GRAVE.
THAT MEANS YOUR REPUBLICANS IN
THE HOUSE MUST NOT PARTICIPATE
IN ANY WAY IN WHAT IS A LAWLESS,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, ILLEGITIMATE
PROCESS, A KANGAROO COURT, A
THREE-RING CIRCUS, AND UNFOUNDED
POLITICAL STUNT.
IT IS TIME TO GIVE THE
DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS, BUY THEM
THEIR SHOVELS, LET THEM DIG
THEIR OWN GRAVES.
LET THEM SCREAM, HOLLER, HEM AND
HAW ALL THEY WANT.
WE CAN WATCH THEM SPIN OUT OF
CONTROL, AND AMERICANS ARE
EXTREMELY SMART.
THEY ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED.
SHARP ENOUGH TO SHOP AT WALMART.
AMERICANS CAN SPOT AN ACTUAL
CRIME AND A THREE YEAR
WITCH HUNT.
MY MESSAGE TO YOU REPUBLICANS IS
YOU CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN THE
NEAR LEGITIMATE,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS.
LET THE DEMOCRATS, THEIR ALLIES
IN THE MEDIA MOB OWNED IT, SLEEP
WITH THAT, THEY CAN DIE WITH IT.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL, SEE WHERE
THE SO-CALLED MODERATE DEMOCRATS
IN THOSE TRUMP DISTRICTS STAND.
REPUBLICANS DON'T EVEN BOTHER TO
SHOW UP.
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN A LAWLESS,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, ILLEGITIMATE
SCHEME.
DON'T SHOW UP AT THE HEARINGS.
YOU MAY WANT TO SEND ONE GUY AND
THE LAWYER TO TAKE NOTES.
PARTAKE OF NONE OF THIS.
WHAT DEMOCRATS -- WHAT DO THEY
VALUE MORE?
WELL, NOT THE U.S. CONSTITUTION.
THEY HAVE THEIR DEEP-SEATED
HATRED FOR TRUMP, THAT TRUMPS
EVERYTHING, NO PUN INTENDED.
DONALD TRUMP COULD CURE CANCER,
THEY WOULD IMPEACH HIM FOR
CURING CANCER.
THE REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED SENATE
WILL NEVER, EVER CONVICT WITH 67
VOTES.
THE VOTERS SEE A GIANT DISPARITY
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT KEEPING
HIS PROMISES, BY THE WAY GETTING
THINGS DONE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND ASSUMED TO BE CHOSEN
DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGERS.
YOU HAVE GOT PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
HAS BEEN THREE YEARS IN SPITE OF
THIS GARBAGE, THIS CRAP, THIS
WITCH HUNT, IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESPITE
CONSTANT RESISTANT HYSTERIA FROM
THE LEFT, TAKE A LOOK.
SUCCESSFULLY APPOINTED TWO
ORIGINALIST JUDGES, PAST THE
LARGEST TAX CUTS IN HISTORY AS
PROMISED, CUT MORE RED TAPE AND
BUREAUCRACY THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT IN 100 YEARS AS
PROMISED.
WE HAVE SEEN WAGES IN AMERICA
HIT A POSTRECESSION HIGH.
JOBLESS CLAIMS IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE THE LOWEST SINCE 1969.
WE HAVE SEEN RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
ALSO ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 70 YEARS.
AMERICA NEEDS TO ASK ITSELF,
WHAT DO THESE DEMOCRATS, THE
THREE-RING CIRCUS OF DEMOCRATS,
WHAT DID THEY ACCOMPLISH THE
LAST THREE YEARS?
CAN YOU NAME A SINGLE THING?
BECAUSE I CAN'T.
THE ANSWER IS NOTHING.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOTALLY CONSUMED
BY UTTER RAGE, RATIONALITY,
DENIAL, AND IT'S ONE POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT AFTER ANOTHER.
COME NOVEMBER 2020 THERE WILL BE
A RECKONING.
REPUBLICANS, YOU CANNOT
LEGITIMIZE WHAT IS A SICK, UGLY,
ILLEGAL, UNCONSTITUTIONAL, WHAT
IS NOTHING BUT ILLEGITIMATE
MADNESS.
DON'T SHOW UP.
DON'T SHOW UP TO THE HEARINGS,
DON'T VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
HERE'S YOUR MANDATE: FOCUS ON
THE LEAD, THE PEOPLE THAT PUT
YOU IN OFFICE TO BE SERVANTS!
BE SERVANTS.
WORK TO GET PEACE AND SECURITY